[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike florio popular co-host of pro
football talk live pro footballtalk.com
must read every single day
keeps you up on all the things rumors
innuendo and of course real news mike
joins us now mike i want to start with
uh a couple of topics that you have
written about one is expansion that
what's going on in st louis with this
lawsuit with the city against stan
kroenke taking the rams to los angeles
and that it could lead to expansion
explain to me time frame the probability
that that could happen
well and here's what we have to keep in
mind first of all the lawsuit filed by
various entities in st louis against the
nfl
isn't going well for the nfl and stan
kroenke who agreed in theory to be
responsible for all of the costs and
expenses
and potential settlement or judgment
he's found some language that would
maybe allow him to back away from that
full responsibility so the league could
be on the hook for it so if those
planets line up in a way that results in
number one a huge verdict against the
league number two stan kroenke is not
individually responsible for it that's
when this idea of maybe dangling an
expansion team to settle the case comes
into play and this is something that was
raised with me i wasn't even looking for
anything about it wasn't asking about it
it was just kind of mentioned as a
possibility this is a way that roger
goodell could solve the problem of st
louis by offering an expansion team now
would have to be negotiated who would be
the owner what would be the expansion
fee where would they play
but dan this all comes down to
legalized gambling the nfl is going to
crave more inventory more things on
which people can bet especially once the
technology is in place to remove any and
all lag from what's happening at the
game site to what's happening on this so
you can make a bet in the 40 seconds
between the end of one play and the end
of the next with nobody being behind
what's actually happening at the game
the money will explode
and they can only get to 18 games if
they can even get to 18 games after that
the only way you increase inventory is
to increase teams so i think it's coming
and the quarterback play has improved to
the point where you could justify more
than 32 teams so it would be st louis
and somebody else and they bumped to 34.
and is it crazy to think it would happen
within 10 years i don't think it's crazy
to think it could happen within 10 years
okay st louis obviously would be in play
give me the other city
well
if the nfl keeps going
you've got
two teams that would be potentially in
london whether it's the jaguars and an
expansion team sorry jacksonville but
your owner has eyes on london and if
they're going to put two teams there
he's probably going to want to be one of
them
chicago they get that new stadium that
they're talking about at arlington
heights bells and whistles third largest
market in the league and
you know if you're gonna build one of
these stadiums the more games you play
in it the more quickly you make your
money back so i i've been talking for a
long time about the possibility of a
second team in chicago the other dynamic
too dan because i think 40 is where
they're going to end up at some point
not anytime soon but eventually they're
going to get to 40.
there's talk at the highest levels of
the league about the wisdom of building
smaller states because for that upper
deck general admission they don't make a
whole lot of money off of that and
sometimes it's more trouble than it's
worth smaller stadium means you can put
teams in markets that we otherwise
aren't thinking about because it doesn't
matter where the games are played what
matters is the game's being played and
anywhere you're sitting on a couch or in
a bar or wherever you can bet on what's
happening in those games it doesn't
matter what city it is we wouldn't have
thought of jacksonville as an nfl city
frankly and i'm sorry to pile on
jacksonville but it's like the number 44
tv market and it's got a team so
it would not be hard especially if they
buy into this idea of building smaller
cheaper stadiums just so they have
places where they can headquarter a team
but are we talking san antonio are we
talking
portland
oklahoma city
i don't oklahoma city i think would fit
i don't know about san antonio because
it's halfway between houston and dallas
and i think those two teams would say
hey don't put another
team in our backyard we want to draw
those fans to our gigantic stadiums we
don't want them following a team of
their own but i think oklahoma city
makes sense san diego could make sense
if you could find a way to pay for the
stadium oakland would make sense but
again in california you got to be
willing to pay for the stadium but the
smaller the stadium and and
it's just the money that is going to be
at play as a result of gambling is
staggering i don't think we've fully
gotten our arms around what it's going
to mean to the nfl but by the end of
this decade they're going to be making
an extra billion a year
from the
early stage gambling relationships that
they're able to conjure it's only going
to get bigger and bigger when the
in-game betting is happening
coast-to-coast or maybe even worldwide
where people can lock in a buck here a
buck there in the 40 seconds between the
end of one play and the start of the
next one he's mike florio pro football
talk live co-host with chris sims that
show uh precedes hours the mac jones
week
uh not official but it's been mac jones
let's uh
slobber all over mac jones here and now
you go into atlanta tonight
um
i don't know if if he how great he is
good he is but he is in the right system
or situation of all of these rookie
quarterbacks now i thought trey lance
might be but san francisco is under
achieve and trey lance is not ready
but
is mac jones good
or is he good for that system that he's
in with that head coach and that
offensive coordinator
i like what i've seen from justin fields
the past couple of games more than
anything i've seen from mac jones but
mac jones fits precisely with what the
patriots are trying to do and sims made
this point earlier today the idea that
bill belichick is trying to recreate
2001
all over again with a young quarterback
who operates within the confines of the
offense a defense that is big and strong
and fast and versatile so that there's
nothing you can do to them that they
can't counter you don't get them in a
bad spot like the rams the other night
where hey we got all these pass rushers
and we got a great cornerback but you're
gonna run the ball down our throat
there's nothing we can do to stop you
belichick can stop you
and also he's got the three-headed
attack at running back and mac jones is
doing just enough and yeah mac jones
isn't a superstar and he may never be
but would tom brady have been a
superstar in any system but the one that
he was in at least early in his career
and so i look i know that there is a
strong pro-mac jones component out there
and there's an equally strong anti-mac
jones component the truth is probably
somewhere in the middle but yeah he he
landed in
the perfect spot for him and he was the
perfect guy for the patriots to have on
the board at 15. okay is he better than
a a fellow alabama quarterback
jalen hurts
well jalen hurts is really coming on
this eagles team you kind of write them
off early and you think it's a mess and
the eagles are going to try to find
somebody else i mean hertz has a
different skill set and would hertz be
successful in new england probably not
would matt jones be successful in
philadelphia probably not but they're
finding a way to get the most out of
hurts and they're focusing on the fact
that they actually have running backs in
philadelphia there was several weeks
early in the season where i think they
forgot that they actually employ running
backs but you know i i think jones is
going to have a lot more staying power
because of where
he is and you look at where that team is
they're going for their fifth win in a
row they've outscored their opponents
150 to 50 over the last four games
and and no one's taking them seriously
isn't that amazing this is the evil
empire of the nfl
and
they they can't stay hidden for much
longer because they have the titans next
week and the bills monday night football
the week after that so we're going to
find out whether or not the patriots
really really are ready to compete with
the best teams in the league well people
don't want the patriots back that's why
i think a lot of people either
consciously or subconsciously you're
like i don't know
let me see
i think with that extra wild card i mean
that's why i picked new england to be a
playoff team i i thought that they would
run the ball play good defense and then
you just asked mack jones to kind of do
what we tell you to do and it feels like
that's their blueprint and has been
their blueprint
and all you got to do is get a ticket to
the table and you've got bill belichick
who knows a thing or two about single
elimination football and also i think
this is one thing that hasn't sunk in
for us yet collectively because we
haven't seen it play out yet with the
extra game the extra week everything
gets pushed back
everything is a week deeper into winter
time so outdoor games
are going to be even more challenging in
colder climates than they otherwise
would have been you got a greater chance
of getting really bad weather you got a
team that can run the ball and play good
defense you're going to be in a position
to win those games if you have to go to
buffalo or if you can get home field
advantage and they have to come to you
mclovin what's the poll question the nfl
one for floria uh okay we had a question
is mack jones the best rookie
quarterback or right place right time is
up on the site right now okay
i say right place right time i like
justin fields and i wish that they would
have just made justin fields the guy
from day one but you like him more than
trevor lawrence than any of these guys
i'm fascinated by the ceiling of justin
fields okay i really am okay yes all
right how about whose career would you
want
matt ryan
drew bledsoe
wow
this is a paulie special paulie do you
want to enhance the poll question drew
bledsoe has 250 career touchdowns 45 000
yards he does have a super bowl ring
that tom brady won but drew bledsoe got
the team to that super bowl game the
rest of his career you could say didn't
live up to things
matt ryan's probably going to the hall
of fame but he is going to be known for
one of the
biggest losses in sports history i think
it's fair to say
i was at that afc championship game too
i was stunned when they went back to tom
brady he suffered a knee injury bledsoe
came in got them to the super bowl it
was a one week turn around i was
surprised by that polly do you have the
career earnings because i think that may
be the difference but here i have a
feeling matt ryan's kicking ass in that
department uh yeah moving on from that
one yeah
but you know can you think of an another
loss in nfl history
that trumps 28 to three
no absolutely not because it happened in
the super bowl it was amazing i couldn't
believe it as it was happening in the
press box watching that game as the
patriots kept scoring and scoring it's
like there's no way in hell and you know
when julio jones made that
circus catch on the sidelines that felt
like the okay
it's it's over now the falcons are going
to win this game they're going to get a
field goal at least on this drive and
sanity has been restored
to houston and the rest of the world and
and that was when you know it all fell
apart from there and the patriots tied
up and it was so stunning that the
patriots won that game
that we we didn't make a big deal about
the fact that the overtime rules
continue to be flawed that the team that
wins the coin toss and scores a first
drive touchdown the other team should
have a chance to match it that wasn't
even a talking point we were so blown
away by what the patriots had
accomplished
i think if the falcons had won the super
bowl and the patriots didn't get the
opportunity with tom brady then this
might have been a bigger deal but if i'm
the nfl network prior to tonight's game
i take the condensed version i take it's
28 to 3
and i pick up
the condensed version from there
and then analyze it just start at 28 to
3 and analyze it in real time and i
think that you could have a fascinating
you know kind of pre-game going into
that game tonight and the thing that i
keep going back to the the decision to
call a pass in a spot where you're in
super field goal range and you get
sacked and who do you really blame that
on do you blame it on kyle shanahan for
calling the play do you blame it on dan
quinn for not saying whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa we're in field goal range here
and do you put some blame on matt ryan
for not doing what maybe a peyton
manning would have done and said to hell
with what they're telling me on the
sideline i got a super bowl on the line
here i'm not going to drop back and risk
getting sacked here and get knocked out
of field goal range so there's one hell
of a blame game to be played when you
get it down to that final moment after
the julio jones catch on the sidelines
where it did feel like the falcons were
going to go up 11 and it was going to be
over
all they had to do
they'd just take three knees
and we would have remembered julio
jones's catch as one of the great
catches in super bowl history instead
you know it's and oh by the way but that
catch was incredible and it would have
led to the field goal that would have
put this away i mean you just you're
watching this in real time and you're
going what are they doing
you know there's too many geniuses in
the nfl
that was the moment that tom brady two
kind of crossed over into
the greatest of all time where it became
imperative to go see him play while you
still could that it was like jordan like
you gotta say that you saw this guy play
he he became
something more than just a great
quarterback with a bunch of rings and
look he's still going i would have never
dreamed after that game
that four years later we'd still be
talking about this career that has no
apparent end in sight yeah
is there another super bowl that
compares another game in nfl history
that compares to what happened to the
falcons
well i i would say that super bowl 49
two years earlier when we had that catch
by
uh
jermaine curse
that was shades of the helmet catch by
david tyree that just created that sense
the pendulum had shot in favor of the
seahawks and they were going to beat the
patriots and then that lightning bolt
interception by malcolm butler different
way that it all ended but but kind of
that stunning i can't believe what i
just saw outcome i think if the bills
had gone on to win the super bowl with
the frank wright comeback against
houston then that might have been one of
those stand-alone games where but you
know buffalo went on and lost
another super bowl but
other than that
you know i mean elway david tyree game
two super bowl 42. let's not forget
about that i mean that was a stunner of
all stunners to hold that patriots team
to 14 points and pull off the throw the
catch the win
that that to me
time causes memories like that to fade
but but that that was
that was one where you just say i i
can't i cannot believe what i just saw
and also the play that's one of the most
important plays biggest plays in nfl
history was not the final play it led to
the touchdown to plexico burst but a lot
of times when we have these great
moments it's like oh it was an
unbelievable run or unbelievable catch
you know and the scramble by e-like to
me is
just as impressive because
mike carey should have called in the
grasp it felt like
and he got away with it the touchdown it
was like did you guys forget the cover
well and you got ellis hobbs who's
ellis hobbit and he's out there he's you
know 5 10 on 6'5 plexico burst and you
know eli sees that and it's like oh
ball game
and and let's not forget this all
apologies to asante samuel he had
an interception in his hands that would
have that would have prevented any of
that stuff from happening yes mclellan
uh what about immaculate reception or
the other end of the hail mary the uh
viki i think it was the vikings lost the
cowboys those are two pretty rough
losses those are those are huge
immaculate uh with the steelers and the
raiders sailors didn't even get to the
super bowl that year though and and that
was weird because back in those days you
didn't get home field advantage based on
your record there was a weird rotation
that they did
the undefeated dolphins actually had to
go to pittsburgh the following week and
play in pittsburgh to get to the super
bowl and did beat them but
there's this confusion over time that
that was somehow a path to their super
bowl win it wasn't it happened two years
before the first time they ever even got
to a super bowl great stuff as always
mike thanks for visiting and we'll talk
to you soon all right thanks dan that's
mike florio he is uh co-host with chris
sims pro football talk live you can see
it on peacock preceding our show